what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way and and guys if
you want to move the Overton window if
you want women to approach you left and
right you're thinking how do I get a
woman to approach me instead of
approaching them get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today I know what
you're thinking you're like
I really love pissed off women in the
comments section they're so funny
they're mad you know on Tick Tock
they're hilarious to watch well why not
get some in person get you a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today the link is
in the description okay
so um we have a couple stories we're
gonna go over today
um the first is a story that I saw
on Twitter as you guys know guys every
night I just go on Twitter and I tweet I
tweet tweet tweet I have all these
thoughts occasionally I even do a
Twitter space to just you know
spread these thoughts so
I saw a video from Dom lucrae talking
about Western culture has destroyed men
and given women the mindset of wanting
more but providing less and I've always
I've talked about this many many times
how basically women in the west we think
were more important than we are and we
constantly have the right in the left
telling us we're so special and the men
must qualify to us when really the
natural order of society is women
qualifying to the men so the Tweet was
this is chilling cultures destroyed man
and given women the mindset of wanting
more while providing less I pray for the
mental health of men and what this video
does is give you an insight into the
average marriage today now before you
guys get triggered yes there are
exceptions but exceptions are not the
rule and unfortunately we live in a
society that does not acknowledge female
nature what is female nature it's never
being happy it's over exaggerating
things it's
um it's always trying to impose our will
on the men you know there's positives of
female nature can't think of any right
now but there are right
um but the problem is we can't
acknowledge the negatives without the
right and the left saying hey but not
all women are like that oh but hey
um you're going too far you're starting
a gender War
even though what we are talking about is
just facts men today are not happily
married wives do not have a good
reputation and you can see this where in
the mainstream media we have things like
happy wife happy life think about what
that implies her happiness which we know
women are never happy
dictates the success of the marriage
it's cheaper to keep her
um that indicates that many men want to
get rid of their wives but they don't
want to lose all of their [__] then we
have man cave
basically implying that she gets the
whole house he is stuck in the basement
trying to get away from everyone because
his wife won't leave him alone uh but
let's see the video let's pull up the
video
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
so this is a common Trope that we see in
marriage this is not just one instance
this is really common we saw it with
Kanye before our eyes where the woman
lied to the children about the father
and there are so many men that don't
have access to their children in this
country there are so many men where the
woman was actually the reason and the
cause of the divorce
yet the kids think it was the father and
this is why I say time and time again I
I tell kids right or you know adult kids
now but ask your father for his side of
the story more often than not
it's not what the mom said we just have
this tendency to over exaggerate to blow
things out of proportion and
and children go through their life
hating their father even though their
dad really did everything right
and the sad part is a lot of men in this
process commit suicide you know and this
is why I I just can't in good faith
promote marriage not the way it is today
um
I think families are good for society
but we really have to push for these
laws to be changed nothing we cannot
have a stable family unit without the
laws being changed it is not fair that
men have to gamble everything really for
women that
typically or over the age of 25
typically have some sort of past and
typically
um really don't add a lot of value to
that the average age of a wife in the UK
is 31. there's no Purity there's no
youth there and a lot of times they
bring in other men's kids
that and men go on the dating apps where
women have really high expectations we
only swipe right five percent of the
time and it's a vicious cycle where
Women's hypergamy has really gotten out
of control
and even more than that I think our
narcissism has gotten crazy out of
control because anytime anytime I bring
up a video like this right anytime I
point out these problems with marriage
one um the first thing that they bring
up is not all women are like that which
I I think that's like water is wet
and I also think it takes away from what
women's true nature every woman is
hypergament every woman has a nature to
impose her will on men now some women
are protected or they avoid it and they
don't end up going to that nature but
the point is women are a certain way and
the problem is we lie to men about the
way women are and act like we're these
sweet angels that can just do no wrong
when really
there aren't many wives nowadays that
submit and obey their husbands and this
is why I tell the guys
I honestly I would just throw out all
the chicks
pretty much over the age of like
24 even 23 these days and really just
get a younger chick
and mold her the older women
I mean maybe one or two can get through
that work really hard but and I say this
after interviewing hundreds and hundreds
of women and I just one day I asked
myself what percent of these women are
gonna make really good wives
I don't know I thought maybe 10 out of
hundreds maybe 10.
um and that's really that's not a lot
and I I think it shows the state of
Western women today we've been lied to
about her nature and typically
um they've made institutions that really
protected women from ourselves you know
um they had our dad pick out her
husbands because clearly we make
horrible decisions
uh look look what's happened the last
hundred years when women have gotten
more and more Choice we've chosen poorly
right and we T we or the tendency for
women to go for men crazy out of our
league
um or for women to believe in like fairy
tales and delusion you know we used to
have the men protect us from this but
the problem is we've given men no power
and no Authority in this Society
and then wine when we're not protected
and the point is we're either equal or
we're not and if we're not equal then we
need to start giving up some of our
freedom to the men in order to have a
better society and that's where
I really get frustrated with um some of
the blue pill guys because they don't
understand that the root of all of these
issues is the policies that are passed
and we need to work to change the laws
in order to fix Society because women
we are just so easy to like propagate
like anything you put in into our ear we
just believe so it's like we have to use
that
and really use propaganda and media
techniques where the housewives are cool
again I know I know this sounds so silly
but guys cardi B is cool Kim Kardashian
is cool look at the role models women
have on TV
um men are not the same as women women
we want to be like the cool girl I don't
know what it is about us but like think
about this guys we are at home happily
with children and they convinced us just
with some propaganda so I say all right
this is my my theories all right I think
one the men have to marry virgins again
I think two they gotta propagate the
women right back I think we gotta put
some like women on TV that are just
really cool Housewives all right
um maybe ban us from social media I know
that's a little hypocritical
um
and and and change the divorce laws uh
women should know that if you leave this
marriage you are not getting your
children I think men should have
automatic custody
if men are paying child support I think
if you can't afford your kids give them
to the men that's my personal opinion on
it
why if I get a dog I have to afford it
like they check my finances I can't go
adopt a dog how crazy is it I can't go
adopt a dog
without them checking my finances to see
if I could afford it but these hoes can
have kids left and right and make the
men pay for it imagine now I'm gonna I
know kids aren't dogs okay I know I know
but imagine if I got a dog with a guy
and now I make the guy send me dog food
money every month that would be stupid
and I'd be like you can see the dog
three days a month you need to pay for
it we would all think that's silly
um and if she's a good mother the dad's
gonna want help anyway so he's gonna
give it's not men are men are a lot
Kinder than women
sorry ladies the last hundred years
when we have been given more freedom um
we really haven't been very nice with it
we haven't been very kind with it we've
taken rights away from men and really
treat men as a sub human class to be
honest with they don't have any rights
to their kids they have very few rights
in divorce court and this is what
happens when the politicians started
catering to what women wanted
always a risk of investment and there's
no guarantee of any kind protect your
retirement with gold Ira or go to
www.justburlythingsgold.com or call
877-646-5347 Noble gold is who I trust
the US has lost 85 percent of its value
since the 70s when the dollar decoupled
from gold and the government seems bent
on continuing the tradition from now
until after the next elections the
government can print as much money as
they want and the last time they did
that inflation went up nine percent gold
is the one asset that has proven to
withstand inflation invest in gold with
a noble asset Investments you will also
get a 24 carat quarter ounce gold
standard coin for free go to
noblegoldinvestments.com now that is
noblegoldinvestments.com or simply dial
1-877-646-53
or seven noble gold Investments the only
gold company that I trust ever since
women have entered the school system
grades have dropped IQ tests have gone
down standardized testing has gone down
and the reason for this is in the 70s
and 80s they made School more subjective
so I'll give you an example when I was
in school I could fail a test and still
pass the class so I could not pass the
test but I could do essays papers all of
that stuff which tends to lean more
towards women it's more subjective which
again goes back to the egalitarian model
and you'll hear teachers say phrases
like you know there's no wrong answer
what do you mean there's no wrong answer
like how do we have teachers
saying there's no wrong answer or
there's no stupid questions
okay so and I I talk about how really
you see a lot of this liberal woke [__]
enter Industries when women enter by and
large so for example you know you see HR
coming in you see all these sexual
harassment lawsuits come in even though
like the men don't complain about this
you know that's the thing women will
like dress like hookers to work and then
be mad when the men you know
say something anyway so there was a boy
in Colorado twelve-year-old Jaden who
was kicked out of class yesterday in
Colorado Springs for having a Gadson
flag patch which the school claimed has
Origins with slavery the school's
director said via email that the patch
was disruptive to the classroom
environment here is the clip
so there
um the reason that they do not
is due to its Origins
with slavery and slave trade
that is what was
as the reasoning behind us like the gads
of black the don't tread on me
which is the yes okay
okay so he he
um
he's what's gonna happen if he doesn't
pick it up
he I mean he is able to go I was
actually just telling him like I was
upset that he was missing so much
school I'm like ah so I asked if can he
just take his stuff out of his bag and
go back to class like I just want him to
go back to class the bag can't go back
it's got patch on it because we can't
have that in and around other kids so
that's what I was trying and then he
said you were close so I was like oh
yeah it has nothing to do with slavery
that's like the Revolutionary War patch
that was displayed when they were
fighting the British like that wasn't
that's the revolution maybe you're
thinking of like the uh
um the Confederate pet our Confederate
fraud okay I so
by the district
and definitely you have every right to
not agree with it I mean
says that he's allowed to wear that if
you like go on their website it's like
says in a big so Butters all I'm saying
is unless there's like a ban on patches
period like you said there's no patches
allowed at the school you cannot display
what you think or anything like that or
what cheer or anything like that
um I I don't I think it's like one-sided
you know because you allow some patches
but not other patches
these American flag
backpacks yeah
okay one how funny is it oh this is
hilarious
that this 12 year old knows more than
the teachers about the Revolutionary War
this is where the This Is Where The Red
Pill sort of meets
um politics because in the red pill guys
when I listen to men talk about dating
teachers they have the worst reputation
especially like middle school and up I
don't know why but it's so funny to like
see this in real life
where it's like these controlling women
that like didn't have children or now
trying to like police your kids you know
how funny is it the 12 year old is
smarter than the teacher
how how hilarious is that and the funny
thing is this lady is talking about how
oh well he's missing class for this oh
like we don't we but I'm concerned about
him missing class well then stop pulling
him out of class and do you think do you
think they would have cared if it was a
black lives matter patch
an lgbtq patch but it's so funny
whenever we have any pride in our
country the left
and [__] typically will will try to
make you feel bad about being proud of
your country where you came from what
you stand for if it's anything
conservative but anything on the left
anything anti-family is just perfectly
okay
um I actually think that men should only
be taught by Matt yup I said it I think
men really need male role models and I
really think we really need to push men
to go into teaching but the problem is
um one there's a lot of risk for men
going into teaching with false
allegations if I'm being honest both
from other teachers and honestly from
students and it makes it a lot more
risky for men to go into teaching the
other problem is we really don't give a
lot of respect to male teachers women
don't typically want to date a male
teacher so you have to look at what
incentive do men have to go into
teaching are they really giving respect
for it not really
um
and now there's more and more risk with
working with the youth so
um Connor boyak on Twitter broke this
down so the teacher cited um UC EEOC
which admitted that the flag originated
in the Revolutionary War in a non-racial
context but they said however whatever
the historic Origins and meaning of the
symbol it has also been sometimes
interpreted to convey racially tinged
messages okay and this is I want you
guys to pay attention to this because
this is the trend that you're going to
see whenever people are interpreting
history in a way to push an agenda or to
make money what they'll say is we cannot
believe the people at the time but we
have to put our goggles and our lens and
interpret it through that lens I'll give
you an example this is the way that
feminists will say that we can't trust
the women at the time to tell us that
they were happy we have to look at it
through our lens they must have been
oppressed they couldn't have said
anything if they were unhappy they
couldn't say it so we have to interpret
it now all you can do is look at the
outcome and honestly what people said at
the time that right there is a future
president that that kid is hilarious and
I just loved how he was just sitting
there like
I could just put a thought bubble like
this [__] is trifling
um okay update on the Dylan Dennis story
um so Dylan danis leaks a video of Logan
Paul's girlfriend asking for someone to
recommend her a big fat
uh that can destroy her body let's pull
up the clip
by the way I'm very proud of myself this
is the longest I've ever gone without
sex since I started
obviously it's driving me crazy
struggling
I mean penis inside of me
ASAP I think all I want is like a big
fat sausage just
destroying my body
so if any of you guys know a good deck
that doesn't have STDs on it I'll take
it right here I can't believe she posted
all this voluntarily that's a funny
thing about us ladies it's like we'll do
anything for attention attention really
is our currency so you might look at
this stuff and think why would why would
anyone post that well
that's just that's just how we are and I
I see this stuff I'm not surprised you
know but you know we are how we are
um
now Logan Paul has now said that this
has not affected his relationship with
her and it's only made it stronger
here's the clip and Nina's she's a
[__] angel bro I don't feel like
going online she's like the nicest
person I think for him he was hoping he
would try to break you guys but if
anything's probably made you guys
stronger so much stronger so it's like
yeah I love this girl so [__] much
yeah nothing will get between us not
some [__] fake lying Internet troll
whose life has devolved to pretending to
be a fighter
just want to know how he rationalizes
all of this you know maybe you could say
she had a past she learned from it okay
you know I I could maybe understand that
thought process but the idea that this
chick's going online and talking like
these are all long-term relationships I
don't really buy
um
but you know I don't know her personally
I'd love to I'd love to get her on a
show and ask her like what her
interpretation of all of this is you
know I feel like if everybody's talking
about her they should at least give her
the chance to
go through explain them I I don't know
but this is a lot guys
um we still haven't seen the video that
will quote unquote end their marriage I
guess we'll see at the fight but yeah
guys pick pick your chick carefully this
is why I say go for the 20 year old
chicks that don't have a mountain of
evidence against against them on
Instagram you know yeah go for the 20
year olds the US dollar has lost 85
percent of its value since the 70s when
the dollar decoupled from gold and the
government seems bent on continuing this
tradition from now until after the next
elections the government can print as
much money as they want and the last
time they did that inflation went up
nine percent that means one thing the
security of your future and your
family's future is all in your hands
make sure you freeze the value of the
wealth you are holding invest in gold
with Noble gold Investments gold is the
one asset that has proven to withstand
recession inflation and just above all
economic threats Noble gold Investments
is here to help you if you want to
invest in gold you will also get a 24
Karat quarter ounce gold standard coin
for free go to
noblegoldinvestments.com now that is
noblegoldinvestments.com or simply call
1-877-646-5347 Noble gold Investments
the only gold company that I trust
there's an Instagram model that offered
to pay an NFL player's fines if they
injure her baby daddy during his NFL
season
um yeah like okay I don't know why
anyone would trust this to begin with we
can't even pay our student debt or our
credit card bills you're telling me this
old this responsible only fans model
is gonna
is gonna pay your bills if you play
against my baby daddy this season please
go for the knees maybe a hammy he's
number 33 for the Dolphins I'll gladly
sell you back any fines let me not get
started on the things this man said to
me while we are pregnant with the child
he asked me to have we got pregnant
after traveling together during off
season his response to my pregnancy was
straight up well what did you expect I
knew it was gonna happen
then he tells me he has a sex problem
and I'm the sixth pregnant woman in
three years the others just had abortion
but I'm already 14 weeks in at the time
he of this confession
I'm gonna I'm gonna address part one
there's like three parts to this
what did you expect and guys this is why
like we need to put some accountability
on the women
yes yes if you go after NFL players
a lot of them get sex thrown at them 24
7 a lot have a sex problem a lot have a
lot of sex with a lot of different
chicks now
you can either accept this or not accept
it but please do not do not get pregnant
and then whine later and act like there
was no warning signs you had no idea I
am warning you now I'm this is to the
women I'm telling you now if you go for
those guys that's probably what comes
with it please do not cry about it later
and go get pregnant by your average guy
there's a plumber down the street
that'll be faithful there's an engineer
and even those those are still above
average let me go even lower actually
there's a guy that works at McDonald's
at Costco at Walgreens that is there and
ready
to be loyal to you and if you don't like
it then please stop going for the one
percent of the one percent of the one
percent
all right so fast forward to
mid-pregnancy my son has a heart
condition and needs a cord blood
transfusion but I'm not a direct match
and Eli is doctors set up the
appointment to give him 30 million meals
just 30 ml of blood and this man refuses
because I found out he was smashing
different women in every city he went
too raw so he blocks me this is I want
to translate this for you guys because a
lot of you are probably naive and don't
understand
um
honestly and I and this is going to be
pretty blunt uh maybe they planned it
I doubt it
um but this is code for
I knew he was a cheater going in
and then
um basically after I got pregnant and he
was locked in for 18 years I decided to
be an absolute menace to his life to the
point where he really was kind of hoping
that the kid would be aborted or would
pass away now I'm not saying that's a
good thing guys but a lot of men get
women pregnant and realize this woman is
from the devil and they're going to be
stuck with her for 18 years
and really my question is so you were
just this perfect angel
and he was hoping that you would abort
the kid
because you were just a perfect angel
and pleasant to be around I want you
guys to just listen to these stories and
realize they make no sense now I I'm not
defending that right I do think you
should do the blood transfusion for the
kids but it's like
okay now you're gonna be an absolute
Menace because he slept with other
chicks
after going for an NFL player oh my God
I just have no sympathy I have I have no
sympathy okay and after he told me it
was best for the baby to die I went
crazy on him and his mama because girl
your son is a POS so I had my son at 25
weeks one pound 12 ounces and my son has
had two surgeries and this man has
I'm guessing not paid for the surgeries
yeah like isn't it the consequences of
your own actions
um
again most men are excited to have
children with women that are nice that
are fit feminine friendly and nice to be
around what they're not excited for is a
woman that is so crazy like think about
it if she's publicly
asking putting a hit on this man
basically
what has she done behind the scenes what
this says to me is this woman is batshit
crazy and now he wants nothing to do
with her yeah and I and I think that he
should press charges and I think that
she should go to jail and face jail time
but the problem is women know there's no
consequence for anything to the point
that we're able to publicly commit a
crime
and know that nobody is going to hold us
accountable so really we need stricter
laws and we need to come down on women
committing crimes we want it to be equal
here's your equality
there you go
um but I got I got no sympathy for women
that get cheated on by NBA players I got
no sympathy for women that whine and
[__] about the baby daddy that they
picked pick a better baby daddy all
right no no man men just magically
change after after children and
commitment that's women you're putting
the way women operate onto men men are
typically sort of how they are and
that's why we need other men in our life
to that man because
obviously we don't we don't pick well
okay so another um I'm reacting to
another video from home math on Tick
Tock and
and YouTube so whole math is an account
that really does a good job of making
visual representations of the dating
market so it's interesting I've seen
like Sim like obviously in the
manosphere we've seen similar stuff like
this for years but he does such a good
job of describing the female experience
I was just really really impressed so he
has this series where he just interprets
like things women say on Tick Tock so
why don't we pull up the click clip of
the standard female delusion chart for
dating this is the standard female
delusion chart it is a tool for bringing
balance back to the dating Market the
standard female delusion chart is
replacing the old chart because there
was some confusion here's how the chart
works we all know that only a few people
are very dumb most people are average
and a few people are very smart this
creates a shape called a bell curve it
works the same way with other traits
like height and attractiveness most
people are average I received a lot of
constructive feedback about the old
chart I was told that men and women
match up evenly but that's only true in
long-term relationships so this is how a
woman would see men that she knows maybe
25 men at most the other 4 billion men
however she would see like this as you
can see most of us are disgusting and if
you are a male three or below you're
this cute little ghost
so generally speaking men rate women on
a bell curve and women rate men on a
jezebel curve and of course it's true
that some men underrate women but other
men overrate women and they are people
so it balances out
on the other hand women rate men they do
not know as 80 percent garbage this
model is supported by data from every
dating app by going outside and
listening to women when they talk it
depends on what he looks like probably
based on someone's personality you could
really hit it off with someone but
attractiveness is a big player of it
that sounded very shallow and by being
attractive if you are a man who has
moved past this line you'll know what I
mean
the standard female delusion chart can
help keep women out of the sleeper Zone
where they languish in emotional neglect
waiting for commitment that was never
coming it works by correcting ludicrous
female perceptions like this let's go
through the chart piece by piece you can
pause on each one to let them sink in
this is how men see women normal this is
how women see men brutal this is how
women see themselves delusional and this
is how women rate other women publicly
everyone's a 10 and privately
I'll go into more detail in an upcoming
video on YouTube for now feel free to
take a screenshot and use the chart
yourself just make sure to credit me or
I will sue I'm also creating a
comprehensive rating system to help
everyone know their level once you know
your score just use this equalized chart
to find your match so assuming standard
female delusion a female 6 matches with
a male she sees as 3.8 a female 8
matches with a male she sees as 6.5 and
a female 2 probably has Hobbies or an
adorable fur baby
the standard female delusion chart can
go a long way towards correcting female
Ridiculousness but only if you're honest
if the standard female delusion chart
makes you mad stay mad forever it's
great for the algorithm I'll be back
soon with instructions for giving a fair
rating until then good luck
you like being approached in public by
guys it depends on what he looks like
probably like to be to find below
average hey like
just look around no I own your place so
the next one is how women get stuck on
their highest setting
I've had women tell me that men go back
to their exes too and that's true but
this video is demonstrating what men do
not do women get stuck on their highest
setting once she's been with this guy
all of these guys look like that men on
the other hand when we lose you and we
look for someone else we do this and
this and this so what I thought was
interesting about this video was it
really does show the problem in the
dating market so again women were never
happy we always want better and better
and better and you see this because
they've given us all these rights and we
whine more and more and more and you can
see it in the dating Market because
really
um women date out of their league all
the time we're all of us probably would
have been thrown out a hundred years ago
so whole math what he's really doing is
showing the problem with the dating
Market you know now all right so there's
always been the peasants and the Kings
right and the peasants knew if the king
came in town he could just steal her
[__] like this isn't new information
that the king wants your wife she's gone
NADA he's just gonna you know there used
to be the two tribes they would fight it
out and if your husband died boom they
killed the kids killed your husband now
you're part you're with this guy that's
that's just our nature it's not very
loyal sorry guys
um and so the problem is today now we
have average women that have access to
really the modern version of Kings top
one five ten percent men and it's not
like women you know we go in you know
thinking oh this is a top ten percent
man we we think they're on our level
because that's that's who's given us
attention and the problem is that's why
we have this extreme delusion where we
all think we're hotter than we are I
don't you know what's funny I've been
asking for ratings on the shows for a
year and a half now I don't think any
chick has rated herself below average
ever yeah let that sink in
every chick thinks she's above average I
think the lowest rating I've maybe
gotten was a five
I've never had a four three two or one
even from extremely obese women or
they're clearly below average but yeah I
I'm a really big fan of homath I think
he's hilarious
um and I think he does a good job of
explaining this into a way women could
really like take it because again I I've
seen stuff like this before but he does
a really good job of making it like easy
for the women to understand so last but
not least today I'm going to bring up a
clip from Kevin Samuels Kevin Samuels is
really the goat of YouTube I
I freaking loved Kevin Samuels like I
used to watch his live streams all the
time when I was younger but I really
think it's a shame I I genuinely think
he's a guy that was gone way too soon
like I I think it's such a tragedy that
he died as young as he did and this is a
common Trope that I I hear and I see
from women on the show I'm single by
choice and again you know really single
by choice just means that the men you
want don't want you because no woman is
gonna say no to a guy that's six pack
six figures six inches so you know it's
like either you're shooting a little too
high and maybe you gotta shoot lower
um or you know maybe you got to improve
maybe you got to lose weight maybe you
gotta you know fix your hair or you know
maybe you gotta become a better person
um all of these things
but the problem is simps and other women
have allowed us to just say these
phrases that don't make sense so here's
Kevin Samuel's take on single by choice
they're not single by choice
your choices have made you single but
you're not single by choice
yeah I was on Tick Tock and I just saw
that came up come up and it made me so
sad because I'm like I loved Kevin
Samuels and you could see how many
one-on-ones he did with women just by
the way he spoke and talked about
patterns in society
um he yeah there's no such thing as
single by choice it's either
the the man you want don't want you and
you have to improve or lower your
standards and the funny thing is men
know this innately like if you tell a
guy
um that in order to get you know an
eight or higher he's got to make a lot
of money he's got to be in good shape
he's got to do all these things that
women like
the men are the men are like yeah
duh
and if you say you know you have to be
above a certain level in order to get
submission from a chick the mental kind
of say
yeah
obviously
um but the women on the other hand it's
so crazy when you say you're an average
chick and to get an above average result
you got to improve this is like
you it's like craziness
um but let me know what you guys think
in the comments like the video on your
way out and guys seriously get a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today the link to
that is in the description please like
the video on your way out let's get this
to a thousand likes subscribe to the
channel I'll talk to you next time